goss
kof
vidéo
coffe pendant des pages au pire comme il
errait dans les coulisses à un bon
d'accord soir
dans c à vous en faites pas pour nous
on aime bien parler comme ça on cherche
on cherche en pierre coffe les pavés
ou en bas du slalom a bon j'ai pas vu
jean-pierre coffe où il est derrière mon
cynisme ah ben voilà salut
mon amour
l'on regarde que je
regarde comment ça va c'est lui oui
mapou coude bon ça va ça sent la voie
d'un peu ouais hein quoi serait fait
bizarre d'être là c'est quoi c'est une
odeur de loges c'est particulier le nord
ces dernières donnent leurs signatures
de peinture parce que ils font tous nos
fils titus et une maison fait tout est
neuf mais
il ya une odeur très particulière quand
on se balade dans les loges c'est un
truc inoubliable il n'osera pas ça n'a
pas la même odeur une loge de cabaret
une loge de théâtre loge de cabaret ça
sent vraiment la sueur aussi ça sent le
travail la besogne l'effort dès qu'on a
été dans une revue on ne pense qu'à ça
on pense à cet escalier car même si tu
l'a descendu sans foi tu sais toujours
que tu peux péter la gueule la 101e fois
et ça c'est vraiment c'est toujours une
trouille qui prend l'escalier je me
souviens au début je descendais
l'escalier j'avais une chaussure de
smoking qui était qui était pas assez et
tout à coup sûr 200 comme ça et tout à
coup le la godasse pourquoi par la
saleté en chaussettes là dedans il ya
toujours un trou est une chose mais
parce que la bio de la part accordée
il ya toujours cette machine dans la
tête haute une binaire d'escalier qu'est
ce que je fais ce ne sera qu'une marche
si suis pas trop ces machins qui prend
vraiment tombé fois
je me suis évanoui réd tomber ouais
je crois que j'avais un petit poêle
abuser on va boire un coup on va le voir
sur in arms au pinard oui
tu vois tu vois ça ce qui est formidable
c'est que quand on est dans la salle on
voit pas les traces de fond d'un tout ça
c'est des trucs tu vas toucher c'est
formidable sa vie il n'y a rien de sain
ça donne des gens heureux et moi c'est
ça qu'il faut savoir c'est que dans ses
spectacles la ja il ya
l'équipe skil fantastique et tout va les
mecs qui sont crevés les filles sont
fatiguées elles sont des problèmes de
santé de mecs de tous les arrivistes et
le sourire est toujours vrai parce qu'il
n'y a rien à faire quand il faut danser
tu veux pas danser fatigué et comme tu
es dans une troupe entière une ligne et
y en ait un qui n'est pas l'agent bon
moment les autres tape
et très émouvant pour moi d'être là
dans les musiques quand le la plume
lalbenque en même temps on a pu faire ça
pendant un an ouais c'est affreusement
fatigant parce que ça demande une vraie
tension ce que des gens sont là pour
s'amuser donc on est obligé de payer
concerné c'est pas un truc que tu fais
les pieren de doigté pencheront pendant
tout l'été un petit mot d'une énergie
c'est pour ça qu'en fait tu es obligé
d'y passer le temps mais dans l'e tron
est parent en même temps m parce que il
y avait une chanson que j'adorais
l'alcazar c'était de ci de là des six de
la quinqua c'était une vache me
va 30 y va petit âne valent aussi de la
quinqua le picotin te récompensera
et ceux qui goûtent
battre a dit lemaître jeune homme quelle
question
ces dix hommes qui ne savent pas ce que
c'est le vin ne sert que du champagne et
des cocktails vous savez un peu agitée
est-ce que les gens boivent encore des
cocktails
ça se perd en lors de battles tulle a
demandé par bouchonné je te reconnais
pas
ouais
[Musique]
il
on serait dans la cave devrions le voir
et panneaux température que ça
épatant n'hésitez pas remis sur
remplissez les verts n'ont versé pas
trop qu'on en ait encore on se donnait 4
kg amérique surtout beaucoup voient en
bois bonjour pour apple dis donc qu'est
ce que c'est cette saloperie qui vous
fait notre jour où il sera inhumé coin
de champagne dans le champagne on met du
jus d'orange et moi je trouve ça
dégueulasse le jus d'orange avec le
champagne sauf que bristol ya un max et
le faire c'est faire le mimosa peine du
mimosa et angoisse à l'hiver parce que
le minimum mes parents habitent d'abord
le limousin et le mimosa fleury l'hiver
donc on va du mimosa l'hiver et l'été
fait tout à faire des bellini revient à
huy dp démission
de la magie c'est formidable bomba
latina la tienne mon vieux
à
[Musique]
c'est quand même formidablement
qu'est ce que c'est bon les
le bon vin ça
c'est vraiment une balade tout à coup tu
t'envoles tu fermes les yeux tu sais
plus ça met de bonne humeur c'est pas
les bons vins ça m'a vraiment de tout
épatant le vin c'est quand même le
meilleur des trucs c'est ce que m'a dit
au port l'autre jour et il me dit la vie
est mieux avec un coup dans le nez mais
personne n'ose le dire
tu sais ce qu'on avait réussi à faire
avec mon pote quart mais on avait on
arrivait à très bien gérer nos ouais on
les balades et on les faisait durer plus
longtemps possible cette femme usante
c'est comme l'amour le sou le coin comme
le sexe je suis pas trop ce qu'elle aime
par deux pas de ces choses là c'est fini
je pense plus mais de 20 c'est bien
mieux que l'amour n'a pas de déception
armand avec le vin si tu choisis bien
tab à 2 alors qu'on annonce été choisis
bien tu peux malgré tout des soldes
alors avec lui qu'on gérait et nokia ont
les décideurs et puis on les monnaies
comme ça où on arrêtait on parle
cette j'aurais quand même temps notre
amitié ou fuite d'abord et ensuite votre
habiter à
on en a fait des plus d'une nuit ouais
faut des plus d'une petit à petit
maintenant a fait ou en avait acheté le
bordel de tour quand même ah bon ah bah
oui ça fameux téléphone 48 heures
apprendre ce qu'est ce que c'est on
allait du notaire qu'est-ce que c'était
très agréable pas tellement bourré comme
il n'y a pas pire des cas le club
attendait le bordel de djougou
allez on en a on en a mené de très très
belles défini et par mu de plus tu as
par bus et par bus comme l'écrit mais il
ya des choses que je peux pas faire
c'est depardieu c'est pas un peu le même
prénom depardieu il boit que son vin
d'abord avant que c'est peu dire c'est
et puis il doit il boit beaucoup et il
boit
[Musique]
on peut pas boire quand on est
désespérés or l'uib moins à une cadence
telle qu'on a l'impression qu'il est
désespéré il boit pour oublier vous je
sais pas pourquoi d'ailleurs lors se
demande ce qu'il a oublié où
tu peux pas expliquer les raisons pour
lesquelles déjà en bois à vide est
sûrement très malheureuse vauban
bêtement comme ça mais
il est en fait c'est toute la différence
entre et sous être ivre ou est gris
comme on disait dans le temps les
grilles les grises et grise et d'une
régionale et les mûrisseries des grisons
c'est vulgaire alors qu'un mec ivre
finalement elle s'est accrue côté digne
dans l'ivresse dans les brille et et
oui mais d'ébriété
tout juste avant après c'était un livre
est celle du président et la voiture tu
peux tu peux oublier ta femme très
adroite tiré c'était une vraie folie
l'ivresse quand même c'est quoi le
meilleur vin que jamais
le top si tu dois partir une sur une île
déserte
excuse moi de te dire que c'est une
question complètement con parce que ça
ne veut rien dire c'est avec qui on les
lois d'enfants sont les mois
le meilleur vin jégu
c'était avec car mr
on était un jour chez manière quand
manière était à saint paul les valence
il avait une espèce de gros
caravansérail de brasserie pour vautier
ridicule on était tous les deux manières
était dans un coin il était avec son
copain des deux rivales il travaillait
ces foutus d'albiol nous envoyer les
bouteilles formidable qui déboutait de
chéchar des ermitages des cornes à des
contrôles qui des machins à 58 à la
bouteille tracé bon c'est vrai que ça
gomme brûlée ces marais 100 mille balles
à bout de 5 min journal de tijd et on
n'en avait rien à [__] quant à 2 20 du
matin ennuyer coup tu ne t'es vraiment
foutu de notre gueule pour affiner des
très bonnes bouteilles c'est pas con
parce qu'on vous les doigts de voir des
trucs et il vient avec le don et ils
arrivent ils à m'élever domaine de
trévarez j'étais restaurateur à
l'étendre
bonnes bouteilles qu'est ce que c'est ce
truc écoute c'était fantastique ou
fermer les yeux et je disais ça je
disais fermant les yeux on fermait les
yeux et on avait le soleil des baux de
provence qui tapait sur les épaules tu
commençais à avoir chaud tellement c'est
très bon il y avait des odeurs
extraordinaire il y avait un petit
chemin tout au fond je vois encore très
bien qu'étant un petit chemin qui
sont-elles chèvrefeuille et puis qu il
rentrait dans un petit chemin qui était
dans un verger comme si ça avait été un
paradis terrestre où il y avait de tout
des abricots des énormes polonais bien
mûr il y avait des pêches blanc juteuse
qui dégouline partout il y avait rien de
rose est la macro il y avait des grosses
cerises roots et des cerises qui dans
notre enfance on s'amuse avec les filles
pour leur mettre du rouge à lèvres avec
d'esprit y avait deux là il y avait des
mires il y avait c'était un vin qui
avait un fruit est absolument
extraordinaire les vrais examens et on
goûte ça je veux qu'est ce que c'est bon
j'en veux 300 bouteilles pour mon
bistrot octobre heathrow qui à l'époque
fait pas tache verte sur chaînes
présentent leur présentant les réveils
de représentants milieu de la nuit de
mai car les vingt trois heures du matin
jeudi je vais 300 bouteilles je vous
fais un chèque lui on regarde savait pas
qui j'étais ne veux pas vous voir demain
matin
je sentais que la pierre était parfaite
lui dis venez demain matin à 9h à
l'hôtel le lendemain matin à 9 heures
nous qui avons l'habitude depuis pau les
hôtesses que c'est que travailler de
bonne heure on dormait ensemble dans
l'émoi dans le même lit le lendemain
matin à 9 heures on était propre il
était rasé on était nickel et on était
tous les deux apprenant le plus marrer
le métier rentre et on dit ali des verts
sont là vous pouvez commencer à me
servir notion d'aigus qui peut-être sur
leurs tubes évidemment le doit à sa 20e
c'est bien c'est ambiance de cabaret tu
vois c'est presque dommage de voir ça
comme ça parce que
il faut dire que c'est le dernier monte
vieux-mans
le don le genre cabaret c'est palido par
des médecins c'est cette maison tenue
par un mec qui croit moi j'ai connu
israël halal cazin il est il a récupéré
cette maison je veux dire avant de vous
n'arriviez on en a parlé pendant une
plombe
déjà
in health tu peux pas faire ça si tu
allais pas ça je veux dire que c'est un
ami en mer damant les danseurs sont
chiantes et danseurs sont impossibles à
mener heures buffet et la demande cela
chante date ou un truc m mais il
supporter tout ça parce qu'il aime ça
c'est sa vie et tu peux pas avoir un
cabaret comme sur une assise c'est pas
ta passion moi j'aimerais bien être
patronne d'un cabaret j'adorerais mais
pas pour me taper des danseuses
non parce que c'est
parce que saintes à longchamp sûr de
faire des mecs heureux et c'est quand
même pas courant dans la vie de pouvoir
donner du bonheur aux gens
[Musique]
comment ça va sur les filles
ah oui c'est pour moi le martinet
session
c'est moi qui ai pas artiste peintre je
te fais ici j'ai j'ai j'ai un métier
plein entretien avec 7 mai copine qui
m'a un jour et nuit
abouti à la extrême il me prend un jour
est la nuit et après et le bain j'ai un
projet pas après gérard là j'ai pas j'ai
fait les couches après le couche je fais
la panne qui l est russie non elle est
quoi l et l'ukrainienne non j'arrête et
je me garde en tentant attends attends
un moment parce que j'ai besoin de
liquide je vais voir dans la banque de
sperme avec nos cartes bleues pour
retirer le liquide est là maintenant
sans ces sa panda peinture ça sent la
pression la peinture reste à côté je
laisse les gens oublient les gens
sublime on cherche on cherche la couleur
jaune c'est là où j'ai pour ici ici ici
c'est le jeune
ah ça aboutit ça aboutit à un couleurs
sublimes et érotique au mystique
c'est pas le sperme sais pas dans
combien de fois je te dis c'est la bière
moi je fais pas patoine on attaque non
non non c'est pas bien le peintre c'est
pas bien on est piégé par la peinture
c'est pas c'est pas un métier c'est les
pièges on peut plus on se retouve les
temps sont allés au nom du
programme ils vont apprendre la peinture
fruits bien avec notre jamais moi un
honneur
c'est ça c'est ça la mode elle aa je
veux faire prendre il ya donc deux
personnes qui boit c'est tout votre cas
c'est moi et gorbatchev ah ouais
maintenant c'est toi c'est toi moi et
gorbatchev bouddhisme de très bonnes non
il est pas votre cas peut pas être bon
elle doit être excellent doit être forte
excellente quillan au val d'allier parce
que moi je suis bangala futur cherche
ton avis tu vas pas trouvé avec anton
n'ont lâché picasso
[Musique]
tendance
la kiffer n'en déplaise à voler plein de
liernu
les tauliers s'est jusque là bas jusque
là jusque là et tu verras et à partir de
ça c'est le garage de ma [__]
jusqu'où on a besoin pas
avec toi arrête arrête ce jour où la loi
les noms on tue pas les supporter
ça devrait payer une crème dans leur
pays plus ou moins la france + belgique
ensemble 60 millions d'habitants est
tous en super
ukrainien a web sont nationalistes n'ont
ils pas des années on est amateur de
culture ukrainienne
un moteur de notre drapeau et de bubka
au five à être troisième président de la
république parce qu'elle saute plus haut
que les autres que des communistes la
vente non j'étais un gt
gt j'applaudis quand tu étais petit à
petit j'ai attaqué parce qu'il fallait
pour les applaudir
[Musique]
il est midi du mat et moi je me réveille
romain faut que j'y aille qu'est ce que
j'aimais ce matin
j'ai mon costard enlève
nickel par modèle des pièges à ploemel
[Musique]
salue les boss sabich
écran qu'il sut bénard marche seul sur
mon trottoir géré cela en mer des
personnes me fait chier d'appliquer la
politique c'est pas mon blain musulmans
et catholiques manquent -sur le sel
[Musique]
sur un pan ya de cul qui m'interpelle
moi je les ignore mais elles sont soit
lé de mon corps elle se rend vite la
petite gâterie mais non non mon chéri
allez salut la volaille jadot
bon ça va ça va bien et vous ça va bien
ravi de vous voir alors voyager
ils attendent pour vous leur signer des
autographes les gens ils vont attendre
il faut absolument que je vous met
derrière un piano et ben on va derrière
un piano on va s'approcher d'un piano
dans les seuls pays et donc on essaie
mocky votre pied comme ça reprenons ici
c'est sûr c'est moins fou et bien là on
va sur scène alors on accord merci sur
scène on y va
pardon
excusez nous
pardon il s'est excusé nous qu'on passe
alors
merci la dame en vaux michel lam et
enfants je vis tu es jaloux
par ici
voilà il ya un piano là alors ça c'est
très beau parce que ça une scène déserte
il ya toujours une flamme c'est un peu
comme à l'église n'a pu tenir orangerie
odiah que le jésus dans le tabac est sur
scène on est remarqué c'est pareil y'a
plus rien bien toujours mis une main
dire que ce être l'art la vie et reste
ce bo1 c'est rigolo
ça ça ressemble un triano
non ce qu'il faut que je vous dise avant
tout est ce que sinon on a presque
oublié c'est que ma femme elle m'a dit
si un jour dans ta vie tu rencontres
michel legrand et demande lui de jouer
juste un petit bout des moulins de mon
coeur voilà c'est pour elle c'est comme
c'était la saint valentin
non
[Musique]
à
comme une pierre que l'on g
oh
le vif des ruisseaux
qu'ils laissent derrière elles
des milliers de ronds dans l'eau
comme un manager de l'est
avec ses chevaux des toits
comme un anneau de saturne
ballon le carnaval 1
le chemin de ronde que font sans cesse
les heures
le voyage autour du monde
un tournesol
donc ça pleut
tu fais tourner le ton nom
tous les moulins de mort
[Musique]
oh
un écheveau de l'aisne
dans les mains d'un enfant
les mots d'une rengaine
pretoria un peu du vent
tourbillons de neige
comme avant
collomb
sur les chevaux de norvège sur des
moutons de céans
comme le chemin de ronde que font sens à
ce réseau
le voyage autour du monde
autour de ça
tu fais tourner de ton nom
les moulins de monde
en
merci beaucoup c'est un très beau cadeau
que vous fait à ma femme
et à beaucoup d'autres gens
vous êtes génial et dites moi c'est
pourquoi cet intérêt après intel avec
barbra streisand maintenant le film tiré
de singer vous avez un intérêt
particulier pour le parlement de juifs
comme ça pour le côté violon sur le toit
mais écoutez c'est drôle mais mais j'ai
rien de particulier aux deux spéciales
simplement par hasard il se trouve que
je vais à presque à chaque fois qu'il ya
vraiment un sujet vraiment juif saturés
- combien de demandes et oui c'est drôle
mais les gg j'ai fait récemment la vie
de golda mer par exemple la musique
j'avais fait des tas de choses était
bébé c'est pas seulement ça ce qui est
très curieux aussi les américaines ont
demandé des fois de faire des choses des
films sur les noirs des films oui alors
j'ai écouté les américains ils disent
que vous êtes un meilleur compositeur de
musique américaine que sa femme
l'attaquait les membres mais cette fois
on les connaît ses vaches présenter
parce que parce que la musique elle
peinait la musique ouais elle est
partout il n'y a pas de croyait il n'y a
pas de pays pour la même cause et ses
petits vous habitiez ou quand j'étais
petit j'habitais en banlieue j'habitais
à asnières
et je passais ma vie près d'un piano
beaux parents il faisait quoi bon mon
père était musicien même et il est parti
acheter des allumettes quand j'avais 3
ans d'accord il est parvenu un j'ai pas
beaucoup vu ses demandes et on sait
exactement comme le com vous jean michel
jarre a
fallu mettre les animaux
mais s'attendent bientôt maintenant ils
sont peut-être et conseiller depuis le
temps oui alors vous avez vous commencé
comment avec le piano comme ça tout seul
vous étiez un peu un peu triste si vous
saviez était solitaire moi les autres
enfants ça m'ennuyait jeu alors je
n'aimais que ça alors je sais pas ce que
j'écoutais à la radio des chansons ça et
je m'amuse avait retrouvé au piano à
deux doigts je recherchais les harmonies
pour voir comme ça et leur ma mère s'est
aperçu très vite que ce que c'était une
véritable envie et elle m'a fait donner
des leçons tout et je suis rentrée au
conservatoire
très très jeune à dix ans
émis comme ça mais j'étais doué c'est à
dire que douch allait vite et tout ça et
puis âgé de 10 ans à 20 ans pendant 11
ans j'ai fait toutes mes études là-bas
avec les grands mères parce que je
voulais vraiment après oui une vraie
technique de l'apprentissage au maire
j'en ai fait plein de place c'est
magnifique d'être avec les familles
parce que votre soeur a chanté vachement
france le 6 tout ça c'est
la bonne époque c'était bien ça mais ça
revient la peau des phoques le jack ce
qu'on appelle le jack maintenant c'est
la bonne façon de chanter les gens qui
chantent très bien a cappella une très
belle mélodie
des groupes vocaux se connaissaient
portrait 5 d'un nouveau grand repris à
au deep is your love des bee gees
simplement a cappella juste des voiles
sont ils sont combien d'entre eux
supposons que 35 des noirs américains
très très bien et vous vous connaissez
le texte 6,9 c'est un groupe de six noir
américain qui appelle la csu pris un
vrai retour de sam et ses sublimes
[Musique]
e
donc
quel horizon
m
nous
avons
sauvé je suis mal au caire ou et
qu'elle aurait toujours
google wave
d'où un jacques demy vous l'avez
rencontré comment la première fois
jacques demy c'était je venais de faire
un film moi en 1959 au début de la
nouvelle vague quoi l'un des premiers
c'était un film de françois reichenbach
il s'appelle d'amérique insolites et
alors tous les metteurs en scène la
nouvelle vague de jacques demy
tout tout tout tout les jeunes afin
qu'ils commencent et l'aimable
m'ont téléphoné à côté ça et c'est comme
ça que j'ai déjà volaille mais il venait
de finir son premier film s'appelait
lola oui il m'a dit vous voulez faire la
musique ça alors j'ai dit oui et puis on
a fait connaissance puis on est devenu
rapidement des amis inséparables puis on
s'est toujours dit le premier jour on a
joué au faucon face à musical c'est ça
qui m'a jamais ça tout va et on a fait
quelques basses et culte ça a maintenant
ça y est quoi je veux dire les
parapluies de cherbourg ou demoiselles
de rochefort on le passe dans des
émissions de télé les jeunes de 17 à la
géniale il ya des moments comme ça dans
mon voisinage alors oui il écoute ça ils
chantent tous à park c'est pas embêtant
donc d'être un peu un monument
historique non attendez on joue pas non
mais bon on a tout le temps là bon
d'accord j'en profite et là bas ça il me
reste à faire plein de trucs que j'ai
pas je
veux dire c'est tu sais je vous à
l'avenir comme ça à l'horizon à main on
n'aperçoit pas encore vous voulez perdre
juste un truc pour moi moi bien sûr
c'est vous savez dans les parapluies de
cherbourg à la fin quand on est sur le
quai de la gare la main sur cette image
dans la tête et on voit le train qui
s'en va avec marc et cherbourg et tout
ça juste un petit bout comme ça
[Musique]
e
oh
[Musique]
don
[Applaudissements]
ça
fait chaud au coeur
à l'onu
[Musique]
moi
un an
[Musique]
oui
je suis essoufflée
vous fait les cimentiers à pied
la bergère vols à vide ça va bien je
suis un peu est-ce qu'il avait quelques
étages à pied j'ai pas j'ai passé l'âge
mais c'est comme ça il faut faire
attention à laon déborde ça à la fin de
sa vie les propriétaires l'ami un
ascenseur il habitait aussi sienne
ainsi vous avez mal
quand ça va tu fumes quoi chez les tous
connu
divers ah oui tiens bonne idée attends
je vais ranger mon pétards merci bon tu
as c'est vachement body dont un pour un
fait
ça tombe bien ce soir c'est un autre ici
n'ont jamais ici je déteste c'est
du bois et serait bien bonne idée mais
qui veulent y identifiant nom parfait at
war on est dans une soirée vin on a
commencé avec tibet de l'indicé avec
jean poulin on a commencé avec jean
pierre coffe et on a parlé des vins de
là il m'a mis de 20 en tête pour le
reste de la soirée
à la tienne on peut plaisir de voir fois
que je t'ai vu je t'avais obligé à dire
du bien du roi d'espagne qui avait dit
oui c'est vrai quand même pas mal entité
souvient dessin un bas je me souviens
attendra le roi d'espagne pas rien pour
moi ah oui c'est important c'est un
bonbon un rôle été les voir un animal
à cordes n rendez vous dira ce qu'on
appelle les yeux des moyens des membres
et monde saint méen sans farine
il a dit quoi
des choses que je vais pas dit avec
celle aux examens mais du bien des
gentils il m'a menacé
dans ces quartiers antérieur ça arrive à
mener dans son bureau qui est petit que
celui ci alors oui enfin c'est pas une
biros
ce qu'elle va médard et il m'a montré
les pilules alli qui l'a
écrit maïs il a surpris ce tournant
génie mais rien qui mettrait très vieux
on vient qui pensaient qu'ils étaient
français
mais tu sais que c'est bien parce qu'il
est arrivé à réconcilier
aussi bien qu'à rio car à bâle après
tout ce que tu as fait je trouve ça pas
mal
dis moi j'ai vu ton dis moi oui je vais
te demander un truc de l'histoire des
des échecs là t'as vu kasparov contre
ouais alors contre ibm
hybride raison de faire ce match oui j'y
ai trouvé des types les plus dures qu'il
ya aussi des costumes
avant ses proches qu'il est nul il a lu
et d'un type d'ailleurs qui n'a jamais
lu et contré une machine ouais à la
place des plans d'aidé type
intéressantes comme le lotier komorowski
il prend un petit port jeanne
tribales qui s'est le mieux qu'ils
peuvent faire puisqu'elle ya l'histoire
et de l'humanité aurait pu retrouver les
choses comme ça c'est haïti les
meilleurs logiciels à un sur dix sont
les meilleures ventes de singles qui
serait oui
c'est pas pro kasparov tu penses qu'ils
jouent qui joue pas bien pour mes
supérieurs
c'est inné chez les produits cabinet on
se dira t
il à lui il il est incapable de vient de
jouer un témoin
alors de ce qu'on fait il s'en va au
cabinet s'est permis par la loi ici ken
rées liminaire alors il consulte tu
crois qu'ils ont des émetteurs dans ce
métier
vous à quai et fiches et inventer des
systèmes ouais donc qu'on joue aussi
chuté sans dieu oh c'est chic c'est le
cycle et aux dons conduire ces chèques
sont 100 pièces à commande suivi la
suite tu viens enfermé ici jamais ici
avant hier mais ici je viens ici
seulement pour témoin il ya des tests ça
qui habitent ici alors mon message et
nous sommes retrouvés
mais tu vois j'ai ici je vais pas il
n'en est rien précuire ouais
c'est un petit musée ici c'est quoi
c'est un petit musée personnel non j'ai
pas mes amis m'ont donné les tableaux
ils sont beaux ces tableaux
un sas et des tops des tableaux qui les
fait faire
ça mais il ya des familles qui m'en
donnez vos telle hausse à olympie cassou
c'est terrible à le tableau sur la
république espagnole la rétine soline il
n'avait jamais vu celui-là mussolini
hitler franco
ces tableaux qui fait faire si tu as
dirigé dans les croquis ah ouais je
skiais troupes souverainistes oui oui tu
as bien des paniques agit vite au port
autre jour ton copain te croire et c'est
ce qui m'a dit pas a dit un truc génial
mais dit
tout la vie c'est mieux avec un coup
dans le nez mais personne n'ose le dire
c'est un grand philosophe
mais il tient un régal puisqu'un petit
palais et hop au lit à tout prix si
lui n'a pas accepté il ya beaucoup et au
programme échanges séduit il n'a pas
accepté de travailler des partis du oui
puisqu'il voulait qu'ils travaillent
partir d'un croquis ça ne vient pas vous
lis donc il a fait ça mais ça séduit ça
c'est mon portrait laissez lui faire
céder lui oui ce sont des choses de lui
en trouver notre propre ennemi
et aiment beaucoup ça c'est picasso lui
aussi n'a pas accepté un il veut pas
accepter que l'on imaginé mais comment
il était pas très intelligent il ils
étaient horrifiés parce qu'il y est il y
avait fait un film qui s'appelle un
nouvel amour t il est beau mais avis à
ses rivales abida viva la vida
et ça c'est beau c'est boîte heures le
jour on a vu ses rôles dans on est on
est allé voir des gens qui faisaient ça
on est allé voir des artistes assassins
rôle dans les tic qui faisait cinq ans
des bois veiné mystic valley
s'intéresser au sexe entre 10000 et
mystique c'est pas loin oui oui c'est de
lier c'est très lié
réponse ça c'est magritte ça ce franck
etienne les ministres de la culture
lundi à la ministre
il est facile nous à huy facile oui
non et ça c'est drôle parce que ça c'est
une maintenance et en maths
qui on peut dire que c'est drôle parce
que il était venu de se lier aux maths
mais à l'époque il était comme moi il
était très drôle vraiment laissé mais ça
c'est signé pour rim était naïve mais il
m'a demandé de les détruire ah oui et
voilà ce qu'il avait fait
c'est un
sénat qui fait ça aussi
mais ça c'est quoi c'est un livre un
livre le fait avec m
entre qui s'appelle comme ça
et ça aussi c'est qu'on est libre ça
c'est encore un livre se voir sûr mais
je n'ai pas ouvert encore il vient
d'arriver c'est parce qu'il est là c'est
assez beau alors
je crois que si les faits reprochés
complet
ya dans les tests et les papyrus de la
mer dont un derrière vivent de la mer
vivant de diva le vide
[Musique]
non
e
on
en dix ans à lui
tel nouveau semaine
jamel jamel
pas aussi tu prends la tête maintenant
la soirée
[Musique]
ça
si tu dis si justement réputé marc mahy
là je suis institut me prends ma tête je
reste tout ce que l'élève toute manière
ils arrivent ils arrêtent là avec leur
leur technique la roma retroussent leurs
écoles leurs questions séraphin j'ai
croisé un journaliste avec blizzard
ti-jean re6 genre sous un toit genre si
genre eu plusieurs bizarre fois genre
terroriste au genre comme l'appareil ce
prix la réussite moi ça me poser des
questions sur le toit était si ce type
bizarre qui gémit partout et immeubles
étaient bien davidson moi je vais pas je
te mettais artistes et schumi comme ça
dit comme ça lui arrive il a fait comme
ça bon ben on sait jamais rien moi aussi
je suis votre copain je suis la banlieue
comme vous ainsi ben thamer vous écoutez
j'ai pris la parka tu vois je vais voir
ce but son canton à la question je vais
vous parler en toute franchise de vos
problèmes économiques sociaux culturels
quand je sais c'est pas la peine de me
dire que vous avez d'énormes problèmes
vous à céret parmi les gens normaux
je sais que votre père talbot se meurt
et que vous allez très dur vous servir
de crédit comme moyen de locomotion
surtout pas que ce soit vrai j'ai des
preuves si ça marche aussi grave j'étais
binaire graves comme but est tout sauf
grave tu as l'air après j'ai regardé
jeudi le bon temps à l'autre brontosaure
d'abord du quiou voix
on n'a jamais voulu décalant sans
qu'elle sache d'accord un doute qui vous
voit d'abord d'où je lui dis je me
demande quelle est celle judo qu'elle
puisse devant l'aca c'est réparé mais
j'en armand
moi avec mes caddie ou lui avec sa pub
sur la tête là nous deux c'est pas mon
père qui tape ma mère et ma mère car mon
père et de trois pour fermer sa grande
gueule julie
je je je met des gants pour parler c'est
de preuves je peux ainsi qu'aux
séminaires graves sur la foi de koné
fanta avec ta caméra tes questions
t'appelles comment d'avoir tué comment
thierry pierret je voulais comme prénom
déjà dit ça fait un peu fromage mais bon
c'est quoi la caisse quand on m'a posé
aucune question je vais me voir
heureusement il s'était de nouveau ce
maillot c'est ça la question non alors
aucune chance moi je suis tu m'appelles
jamel debbouzze le roi du blues ces
marocains ouais ou français marocains
aux français ça dépend des jours ça
dépend des jours et aujourd'hui je suis
fâché aware les lisons français j'aime
bien c'est quoi ces gentils notez
bien que tu fais
j'ai écrit des sketches
dans la banlieue je pense comme ça sur
les choses qui vous font faire les
choses que sur les trucs que j'ai vécu
je veux dire
et je finalise qui viennent voir les
jambes ont lieu en leur demandant de
leur donnant de l'argent pour qu'ils
fassent des reportages bidonnés tout ça
ça existe mais maintenant ça existe j'en
fais des sketches vient vous voir vous
vis tu verras c'est un truc ça m'est
arrivé je me suis inspiré d'un fait réel
c'est un mec est arrivé avec ses
questions
qui débarqué comme ça avec sa caméra à
cause de questions au départ ils
arrivent en proposant composer sans ses
enfants après une émeute qui s'est passé
il nous a demandé
d'apporter nos témoignages et qui serait
l'avocat du diable en fait il nous a
promis qui mettra en avant la vérité qui
ferait valoir le droit parce qu'ils
partagent voix et en fin de compte il a
sorti et dans un cas larcher plus kaki
lequel s'était
il a on a fait l'interview il avait
confiance en lui et se bat par ce
qu'elle a fait la raconter n'importe
quoi il a transformé la transformer la
vérité et nous prennent nos hotspots on
s'est fait main c'était chaud voilà et
en plus innocent mais n'a pas la vérité
on est passés pour des cons et c'était
tout bénef pour lui mais pas pour nous
il a vendu son truc on et être apte
ouais ouais c'est comment c'est joli
c'est bien comme cela écrit commence à
devenir un peu bizarre dans la mesure où
ça commence à virer ces touristique
maintenant
il ya six cars de crs par son inversion
des passants qui soit 76 par carte c'est
moins drôle de joueur est sauvé mais ça
marche il attendait comme ça il ya vingt
ans puis a pris son parti est seul en
banlieue ouais moi pas tu après 68 ils
ont mis les quarts
sur le boulevard pendant des années on
va pas attendre battant à vous attendez
pas non attendue qui sont à risque vous
attendrez pas
enfin pas tant ceci dit ils sont pas
très méchant ils servent à rien ils sont
là il me regarde je ne portais une
course extraordinaire mais si vraiment
c'est chaud mais tu sais que l'état va
payer des grands frères pour aider les
vieilles personnes aller chercher leur
pension alors j'ai vu ça qu'est ce que
tu en penses de ça c'est une bonne
mesure qu'on ne sait pas c'est ça c'est
pas mauvais comme pro-syriens non ça
sera moi c'est pas très content dans la
mesure où bon c'est sûr que les
contrôleurs par exemple prend l'exemple
des contrôleurs à lier à la sncf à la
ratp il serait constamment et frapper
dessus ouais j'ai vu à blois il ya un
système qui s'est mis en place c'est les
grands frères en fait qu'ils sont là à
l'entrée des cars bon pour faire en
sorte que ça se passe bien sachant qu'on
les respecte et qu'on pourra jamais levé
la main sur eux et qui à cette notion de
respect qui entre nous et c'est un peu
d'air qui les grands frères dans ce cas
là quand même non non mais non pourquoi
parce que non seulement battant pour
pour les plus petits c'est sûr que ce
serait mal perçu mais j'admire les gens
pour une certaine maturité j'ai eu 20
piges tu vois je la découvrir mais je
sais que si demain il y avait un mec de
25 ans 30 ans ne serait pas quelques
mois quand on va me dire arrête tes
bêtises ce mec-là il est passé par là
avant il sait de quoi il parle et je
prendrai du recul avant de faire quoique
ce soit lui dire stop moi je vois ça
peut marcher ce mois je suis sûr que
vous
combien d ici bien d'immigration
et d'effectifs en plus ah oui
y'a un record je crois 251 qui s'est
filmé ces états unis 151 magasins non
mais
vu la tête de la fille après je me
demande si franchement c'était pour le
record vous si c'était pour un plaisir
ouais bah c'est comme traverser
l'atlantique à la rame
mais bon
là franchement c'est vraiment ramé pour
ramener non maximum 7 10 ans mais celui
ci bien plus mon mari lors des entractes
ouais bah mais si on compte qu'une fois
ça fait ouais ça fait 10 mai les vagues
et parures viennent de moi un certain
wayne à when we have et d'acteurs donc
ça peut faire trois ans quand même pas
ouais mais en vaginal ou anal un peu des
deux un peu de bruit c'est passoire
vaginale soient analysés si vous jetez
un choix ouais c'est comme je me sens
bien dans blessure ça fait quel
sentiment se procure
est-ce que tu jouis du début à la fin
par exemple c'est psychologique raid à
faire là mais est-ce que tu joues et le
pas physiquement non mais
c'est jouissif oui il ya un moment tu
abandonnes complètement quoi et n'ont
jamais pas contient une caméra c'est pas
possible si tu fais déjà mêlé d'une
bombe hors caméra tilly et à ce moment
là qu'est ce qui s'est passé tout
abandonner complètement si je me
souviens plus était hors du temps
comme le sont bâchés
c'est ça pour vous de vos vieux con mais
au bout de trois mètres qui s'occupe de
biton air de frais
et après ça ça tourne à vous et
après on a faim et a donné en écoutant
ouais c'est ça qui m'a donné envie de le
faire devant une caméra en fait ouais et
envie de recommencer au juste on t'a
fait l'expérience devant une caméra
ouais mon vers iphone le jeu je trouve
une petite une mise en situation
amusante et pourquoi pas commencer oui
pas dans l'immédiat mais
si j'ai envie de recommencer je
recommencerai pas parce que c'est le
mobile ben là tout de suite mais coach
des bottes
séjour séjour c'est julie ces jours ci
ouais non j'ai d'autres choses d'autres
projets en vue par exemple par exemple
j'ai filmé il n'ya pas longtemps tout un
film ou
ou des petites débutantes sont livrés en
pâture à deux trois voire quatre garçons
en même temps donc j'étais un petit peu
aidé à aimer ça donc on va essayer d'en
trouver une qui a envie de pousser
l'expérience un peu plus loin et puis
on verra bien ce que ça donnera
qu'est ce truc le plus dégueulasse qu'on
fait
j'ai pas fait le truc et que la
dégueulasserie plus si tu dois faire je
préfère
une double pénétration anale au
voisinage bah en même temps ah ouais
mais la double pénalité se méfiera le
monde nous montrent encore des trucs
adecco oui mais toute manière
je fais ce que j'ai envie
peut-être si un jour j'ai envie ça
m'excite d'essayer je fais
autant presse à une double ppm a pour le
moment non
et pour être sûr
à thé de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y
mettez un peu de bleu